[Music]
how has your understanding of and
approach towards minimalism developed
over the last seven years
i think my approach is probably changed
the same way many people's approach
changes
ryan and i will often say that
minimalism starts with the stuff
and so for me it truly started with the
stuff you can call it decluttering you
can call it letting go tidying up there
are all kinds of monikers we can give it
but it was really about it was a
reaction to being overwhelmed by
stuff yeah i had too much stuff in my
life but it turns out that our material
possessions are a physical manifestation
of what's going on inside us i knew i
had a lot of external clutter what i
didn't know is i had a lot of social
clutter relationship clutter career
clutter psychological clutter emotional
clutter spiritual clutter calendar
clutter obligation clutter there's a lot
of internal mental and emotional clutter
going on inside me and as soon as i
started letting go i i started looking
inward and realizing like oh my gosh
there is so much that i still need to
deal with and and at first
when you start to understand the truth
about your stuff and your relationship
with stuff
it causes actually more turmoil
because it's like
oh
i thought things were fine and maybe i
was just one solution away from solving
all of my problems
but then i realized no no they're
actually more
problems and i was covering them up
you know i think about my mom when when
she died because that's how we kind of
started the whole minimalist thing when
when she died i started questioning
everything she died of stage four lung
cancer
had she caught that cancer earlier stage
one
she may have been able to eradicate it
right but instead we wait we wait we
wait until it has metastasized
all over our lives
and i felt like i just had
this sort of metastasy of of clutter
throughout every area of my life and why
why do we do that well i did it because
i wanted to be accepted i wanted to be
successful i wanted to be better i
wanted to be improved i wanted to be
the best version of myself or whatever
that that meant but it was all by
someone else's standards if i buy the
right thing have the right relationship
have the right job live in the right
house own the right car
then i will be the right person
but of course it never worked in fact it
took me so far away from being the
person i wanted to be
yeah it's interesting the
uh metastasizing comment makes me think
about
how you know often people will ask would
you have to have like a major life event
happen to like
be inspired to be a minimalist
and unfortunately
i think that's probably how most people
start down this road
is because they
wait and wait and wait and keep putting
things off until you get to a boiling
point it's almost like
someone who's in a job that they really
hate like should i quit my job right now
because it's like well no you should
have quit it like
a year ago but but a year prior to that
year you should have planned an exit and
like now you're at this point where like
you feel like you have to do something
radical um um and uh you know for me and
i definitely felt like i had to do
something radical where i was on my life
so minimalism it was like radical enough
not because
not for any other reason then
i needed
to change my state i needed a different
perspective on how i was approaching my
life so that's what i saw
minimalism as an opportunity now this
question asks over the last 11 years
but technically it's been you've been
doing this for about 12 plus years right
yeah and you've been doing it for over
11. what's what's fascinating is this
year 2021
is our 30th anniversary ryan you and i
have known each other since 1991. yeah
that's wild and we've been great friends
and on the maximal episode this week i
actually want to go back to our
childhood and talk a little bit about
how the narrative overlay is ryan and i
have been best friends since we were fat
little fifth graders and while that's
partially true it's not the whole story
and we've had times in our lives where
we've grown apart and we've come back
together and so i want to talk to you
about a lot of that yeah you use this
word radical and what's so fascinating
about it is you're right minimalism does
seem so radical to certain people but
the reason it does is because
we've been doing all of these radical
things yeah we've been steeped
in radness
radicalness yeah and we've had so
having 300 000 items in your home was it
that's normal it's normal now yeah
that's what we what i mean by normal
right it's it's average it's the norm
right yeah and yet
if you look 100 years ago 200 years ago
a thousand years ago
that's so radical and unheard of kings
didn't have 300 000 items in their home
dude native americans thought it was a
uh a mental illness
it is yes really i mean so
we are like the level of hoarding we
have now it's an acceptable level of
hoarding because it's average
yeah but you're right a thousand years
ago they would have looked at us like
why are you holding on to so much stuff
right you and your possessions and the
me the mind i'm not against having
personal possessions obviously i have
plenty of them but i do have a problem
with the clinging and we quite often
cling with oh that's mine
in fact we see it manifest a mental
illness there's a guy across the street
this this morning you and i saw him yeah
he uh he's been living literally across
the street from the studio here and he
is i mean he's a traditionally mentally
ill hoarder
and yeah i mean i feel so bad for him
but there's a guy who bought the
building across the street and he even
offered him money and try to help him
out get out of here can i get you
housing is there something i can do here
and the guy has simply refused but he
has i mean i feel like he has 300 000
items across the street you can't even
walk down the sidewalk where he is
anymore and you know it's that's a great
observation because people will often
ask like well how does how does a
homeless person use minimalism in their
life and i agree like there there are
different um people are on a different
socioeconomic scale my problems are
different from a homeless person's
problems right but using that person as
an example
um
he was he's in such a scarcity mindset
that he holds on to every single thing
that's right which actually ends up
being a detriment to him yeah in fact
you and i grew up really poor
you know we hear people all the time so
yeah i uh i'm poor that means i'm a
minimalist right i was like well no we
we definitely weren't minimalists when
we were growing up by the way you're
american poor which is way different
than poor poor yeah here's here's a stat
for you do you make thirty two thousand
dollars or more if so you're in the top
one percent of people in the world yeah
that's crazy you you're a one percenter
right 16 bucks an hour by the way and
and so like
what's fascinating is
we
can get out of poverty
but we often don't get out of the
poverty mindset yeah and that's where
ryan and i were we still had a scarcity
mindset we left
behind where we grew up we climbed the
corporate ladder we spent here's the
weird thing ryan next year will be 12
years for us
i spent 12 and so it's 12 years for me
right now
minimalism since i discovered minimalism
and it came into my life
and
i didn't discover it by the way like i
mean i discovered the way same way
christopher columbus discovered america
right ben franklin discovered
electricity yes like minimalism was
already there i happened to stumble into
it you uncovered it yes i uncovered it
for me anyway it's been 12 years for me
since i simplified my life a little bit
over 12 years at this point so it was
what was that 2009 when my mom died and
my marriage ended both in in the same
year in the same month
that year and i started looking around
and i realized like oh i'd spent the
last 12 years in the corporate world
climbing the corporate ladder but i
still had that scarcity mindset yeah i
was still
clinging grasping now i was clinging to
different things and and i was told that
they were better things but they weren't
better they were societally
acceptable clinging
yeah i was holding on to status
achievement success etc
and there's nothing wrong with those
things as a byproduct but if i think
they're going to make me happy fulfilled
complete
it's just another form of consumerism
and even when walking away from that
world and becoming the minimalist i've
seen times where it's like oh yeah
here's the right way to be successful
well that can also turn into another
form of consumerism yeah and so here's
the main lesson that i've learned yeah
it's gonna ask you like if you had to
highlight it all your understandings how
they've changed consumerism extends well
beyond the stuff
oh yeah for sure consumerism is the
ideology that buying things is going to
make me happy or complete
but
we often shift that well i'll get rid of
my things and now i'm going to be a
consumer of experiences
experiences are great i really enjoy
them in fact the one way to be present
is to experience life however if we
start chasing experiences if i just had
this experience then i would be happy if
i just had this experience then i'd be
fulfilled if i had this experience it
would be better than owning stuff
well maybe but maybe it's also a chase
and so any chase often takes away my
freedom
and i value freedom i value peace i
value tranquility in a way that i didn't
value it in my 20s and it's not good
you'd say that you should value peace
it's just i would say that i wanted
freedom i would say that i wanted peace
but then my actions
would be everything that took me out of
peace
added chaos disorder to my life yeah
then i could go on this entire podcast
about how my
how my opinion or my understanding of an
approach towards minimalism has changed
some of the things that stand out is uh
so for me minimalism there there is no
destination you never have the perfect
amount of stuff right it is a
it is a constant
moving target that you have to
adjust for as time goes on
and uh if anything it just made me
more flexible to
um
towards change
the other thing too is
so we've been i was just listening to
this i forget who wrote it but it's a
book on stoicism and they're talk they
were talking about how
pre-post-industrial age
the
um
the message propagated was
there's a gods there's a god-shaped hole
in your life yes
and like that's what you're missing
missing god in your life and now
post-industrialization there is a
consumerism
shaped a hole in our life yeah and in a
lot of ways the god-shaped hole can
still you know apply to today
so
i thought minimalism was gonna fill this
hole i thought it was gonna like not
make me complete but i thought it was
going to help me
move through life in a way
where i didn't feel like i was missing
something it would fix the problem yeah
so i don't i don't miss anything i don't
feel like i'm missing anything but
there's still a little bit of a of a
void there
and what i've learned
from this journey over the last 11 12
years
is that
that void
it is so much better
to like instead of like
you know in a car
driving away from that void
it's like i i
have it in the passenger seat with me
and really understanding
that there's nothing that will ever fill
that void there might be a brief instant
where
you know i feel like oh everything's
perfect right now and it's true for that
moment but that void will always come
back in some way so for me
minimalism doesn't fill the void
what it does is it narrows it and
it has really helped me accept it if
that like i'm friends with the void now
yeah in fact it's made you realize that
there isn't a should fill the void right
and i think that's the problem in fact
we use the word void as though it's
pejorative i was having this great
conversation with danny this week and we
were here trying to hang these these
paintings that are behind us that didn't
get
hung um and so you're in a weird sort of
transitional pace space of the studio
right now but danny and i were talking
about how a lot of these words are used
pejoratively
and you know there's a word like um
inferior yeah
well of course
you look at that and we've been
programmed to think oh that's bad right
but like if you actually want to grow
you want to be inferior to the person
you're learning from yeah i was telling
danny like there's nothing i can teach
you about audio video stuff now i can
guide you through
your own growth here in so many other
ways but i'm inferior to danny with
respect to audio video yeah now it
doesn't mean i couldn't change that in
the future but in fact if i wanted to
learn audio video i love how the caveat
is in there i could i could totally not
be inferior though but anyway well what
i'm saying is like if i felt compelled
to do audio video stuff yes then i'm
sure i could get good at i'm just not
i'm not compelled to do it really right
but he and jordan are compelled and so
what's fascinating is if i wanted to
become
you know better more nuanced have a
deeper understanding of of the audio
video stuff then i would subordinate
myself to danny because that's how i
would learn from that absolutely being
inferior is actually what you want in
that instance take that back to the void
i want the void
because what's the opposite if you go
into a giant museum and you're in this
cavernous beautiful room it's mostly
empty now we could call that a void
or we can call it beauty yeah we can
call it acceptance we can call it space
open space in fact when you uh when you
go to wyoming or montana
it's not like man when are they gonna
start building all the condos here like
what are you doing with all this space
no it's like wow
look at all this open space isn't that
stunning so the void isn't bad and we've
been told that the void is bad and
therefore because it's bad we need to
fill it with things and when the things
don't work i need to fill it with
experiences when the experiences don't
work i need to fill it with people when
when the people don't work i need to
fill it with creativity when the
creativity doesn't work i need to fill
it with contribution but maybe the first
thing i need to do is know that the void
is just wide open space
and it can be beautiful
on its own
did you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free